فوق طلب عدد من اهالي المعتقلين السياسيين
التونسيين الاتحاد الاوروبي بفرض عقوباتنا
على الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد الى جانب
مسؤولين تونسيين اخرين بسبب ارتكابهم ما
وصفوها بانتهاكات جسيمه لحقوق الانسان
وقال محامي المعتقلين ان طلبه يتضمن فرض
عقوبات على رئيس تونسي ووزير داخليته مع
عدد من اسلافه ووزراء العدل والدفاع
الوطني التونسيين
المشهد وتفاصيله في بروكسل على ضوء هذه ما
طلب به هذه المعتقلين مع مراسل الجزيره
عبد الله الشامي اليك عبد الله
اليوم في مؤتمر الصحفي عقده ثلاثه من
اهالي المعتقلين والمحامي لهؤلاء
المعتقلين
تقدم رسميا بطلب لاضافه
كل من الرئيس التونسي وكل من وزراء
الداخليه والعدل والدفاع الوطني بالاضافه
الى وزيراي داخلي سابقين الى القائمه
الاوروبيه للعقوبات وذلك كما قال المحامي
في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي بناء على
نظام الاوروبي للعقوبات فيما يخص من ضحكات
حقوق الانسان الذي كان قد تم اقراره في
نهايه العام 2020 هذا الطلب الذي اذا ما
تم تطبيقه سيشمل منعا من السفر لهؤلاء
الشخصيات الى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي كذلك
حظر الارصده التابعه لهم ايضا في دول
الاتحاد بالاضافه الى منع المؤسسات
الرسميه الاوروبيه من التعامل معهم يقول
المحامي ان هذه الخطوه هي خطوه اوليه
وتاليه كذلك التقدم لطلب مماثل الى
الجنائيه الدولي
هولندا لمحاسبه هؤلاء الاشخاص ثم ايضا
تقدم بطلب مماثل الى المحكمه الافريقيه
لحقوق الانسان محامي اهل المعتقلين قال ان
ما يراد من خلال هذا الطلب هو ان في تونس
المسؤولون عن الانتهاكات حقوق الانسان هذه
الانتهاكات لها توابع
وعواقب وانها يمكن ان تمر دون ايه تداعيات
علم وتقاليم الذين حضروا اليوم هذا
المؤتمر قالوا انه من ان يتخطى مرحله
البيانات التمديد بوضع حقوق الانسان هناك
الى اتخاذ خطوات عمليه لكي لا يتدهور
الامر اكثر مما وصل اليه الان وان
النوايا لنظام الحكم تونس بناء على
تصريحات الاهالي لا تؤشر الى ان هناك
اينيه للانتراجه او حتى لتخفيف الضغط او
ان النظام هناك يتعامل
الشده كبيره مع كل من ينتقد او يعلق على
وضع وكل انسان في البلاد بالطبع لكي تدخل
هذه العقوبات او ليتم الموافقه عليها
سيستحق الامر عده اشهر بالنظر الى ان
المجلس الاوروبي هو اعلى سلطه للاتحاد هو
من يقوم باضافه الاشخاص الى قائمه
العقوبات والتصديق عليها لكن على الاقل
كما كان ظاهرا اليوم من تصريحات لنائب حضر
هذا الاجتماع نائب البرلمان الاوروبي
وهو عضو ايضا في لجنه الخليجيه قال ان
هناك زياده
فكره وجود على افراد من النظام التونسي
داخل البرلمان الاوروبي حيث ستعرض الى
الامر ثم بدا تطبيق بشكل عملي سيعرض على
الاوروبي قد قال اللاجئات اخرى اشكرك يا
عبد الله سامي مراسله جزيره من بروكسيل